[Musique]
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion que les
membres du conseil départemental des
jeunes font le bilan des actions menées
au cours de cette année une année riche
en rencontres marquées par des actions
de sensibilisation à la sécurité
routière au danger du sucre et une
journée de rencontres dans un ehpad des
personnes âgées que de nous voir et de
normalement plaisir les collégiens de
troisième membre des commissions nord
sud est et ouest obtiennent leur diplôme
de conseiller départemental jeunes un
titre pour ces collégiens engagé au sein
du premier cdj de france
l'avenir de la réunion et au sein de ce
défi et il faut un sacré boulot et on va
fêter cette année les 30 ans du cdj et
on aura la chance d'accueillir les
conseils départementaux de métropole et
les le département elle sera très fiers
d accueillir sur notre territoire et qui
dévouent devons découvrir aussi la
réunion
je vois des jeunes investis des jeunes
motivés et des jeunes qui sont porteuses
d'espoir c'est surtout ça qui
m'encourage tous les cas à faire en
sorte que le cdj puisse perdurer
parce que vraiment on voit l'ambition de
notre jeunesse qui souhaite aujourd'hui
prendre notre destin en main ces
collégiens l'ont bien compris
s'engager aujourd'hui au sein du cdj
c'est pouvoir s'exprimer et défendre les
idées et les préoccupations des jeunes
réunionnais on est peut-être jeunes
faire partie du cdj c'est une instance
politique aussi et le cdj ça apporte cib
en tant que jeunes d'être les porte
paroles quoi de pouvoir représenter son
collège et comme moi par exemple en tant
que présidente de pouvoir représenter
tous les collégiens de vous
[Musique]